I think it's great seeing you in
Jennifer Aniston on screen again
together as 4/5 collaboration you guys
are friends off-camera as well what's
the key with to chemistry there's no key
to it accepted we just really like each
other we get along and she's you know
she's a nice person she's really sort of
human comfortable in her skin and we've
just been a match for a long time your
character in this in this movie is so
cool and calm and collected how did you
manage to stay cool with all the madness
happening on you at this party I mean I
didn't I'd messed up a lot of takes by
laughing cuz there's a lot of really
funny people in this movie and I'm kind
of used to playing that that character
sort of the the steady guy and so I've
got some little secret techniques that I
employ while people are being funny TJ
you literally almost passed out flowing
this I did I became very dehydrated
while rapping because I was rapping mom
I was rapping for for eight to twelve
hours one day in a Santa suit which I
don't know if you know this but they are
designed to be worn in the wintertime
not in Atlanta during June on a
soundstage so that's how hard I work for
you
- IV bags worth of comedy that's for you
we see a whole different side of you
Courtney in this film was it hard for
you to let go and just go crazy or do
you let your hair down this is not how
we see you I'm very fun he's very funny
you really really goes for the turn from
when he you know before the party and
then when he gets to the party really
starts burning he's the craziest element
of the entire it's it's so fun to see
him just go surprise yeah it is a
surprise that's exactly right when he
first comes out of the bathroom he goes
yeah it's one of the most fun elements
of the film you had Courtney be Vance
who's like Nolan for a serious job I
mean he went all the way he went for
something about getting him to go and
let that one you know in a great way
he's um he's an old school theater actor
so he really absolutely right for the
part yeah he trusts the directors and
what he said to us which was pretty
dangerous is I'm completely in your
hands
do whatever you want with me and we were
like okay
[Music]